commission dans lequel six semaines
effectives sur le coronavirus on y
revient le sénat d'ailleurs va donc
lancer sa commission denquête au mois de
juin sur la gestion du kof 19
est ce que vous craignez un procès
politique je ne crains rien d'abord
c'est un droit et donc je n'ai pas à
commenter ce qui est un droit et je
trouve bien que les assemblées puisse
saisir de la question
vous l'avez décrit c'est le rôle d'un
parlementaire mais c'est le rôle d'un
parlementaire j'ai été parlementaire il
m'a peut-être qu il m'arrivera de leur
devenir et donc je je je trouve pas
anormal que les parlement se saisisse de
la question c'est valable dans toutes
les grandes démocraties les commission
denquête sont faites pour ça peut y
avoir une interrogation sur la
temporalité est ce que il ya autour il
ya pas lieu d'attendre qu'on soit sorti
un peu de cette crise parce que jusqu'à
nouvel ordre nous y sommes encore même
si je nous sommes en phase de
déconfinement pour mener à bien les
évaluations parce que je pense que c'est
une évaluation après moi je fais
confiance à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat pour mener un travail sérieux qui
sont un travail d' enquête est pas qu à
charge parce que la question n'est pas
là chargé de regarder ce qui aurait pu
être mieux fait ce qui aurait pu être
mieux anticiper je constate d'ailleurs
que sur un certain nombre de sujets ce
n'est pas seulement celle là le
gouvernement actuel qui est peut être
questionné mais si les gouvernements
pressent le précédent prenant la simple
question des masques et mon ordi
splitter centrale qui les centrales
estion centrale néanmoins il y a eu le
précédent ben halak avait beaucoup créé
des tensions entre l'exécutif et le
sénat puis là on sent déjà une certaine
musique bruno retailleau justement à
propos des masques le président du
groupe et l'air au sénat qui estime que
le gouvernement
je le cite à tromper les français sur le
port des masques pour cacher la pénurie
qu'est ce que vous lui répondre et je ne
crois pas mais l'on n'est pas en
commission d'enquêté parlementaire et il
m'appartient pas n'étant pas mise de la
santé de répondre à ces questions qui
sont parfois des questions extrêmement
technique je trouve que rentrer dans la
discussion nous n'essayons pas de
regarder les processus qui ont été à
l'oeuvre sur les masques par exemple on
voit bien que la politique globale
depuis dix ans était une politique de
réduction je me souviens du procès qui
avait été fait roselyne bachelot
d'ailleurs à l'époque on leur la
soupçonnant de tous les maux y compris
de conflit d'intérêts sur la question
des masses soit sur la question des
vaccins compris des émissions télévisées
que lourdement insisté sur le fait
qu'ils avaient des choses pas normales
qui s'était passé à 7 mois et donc on a
baissé collectivement lagarde bon très
bien
prenons acte de cette situation la
commission denquête il faudra aussi
qu'elle montre ça comment un état un
pays comme le nôtre peut se mettre en
situation de pouvoir répondre à une
crise sanitaire
reconnaissons lui qui était très
inattendu une dernière question sur
cette commission denquête est ce que
vous confirmez
les propos rapportés par le canard
enchaîné qui dit que le 7 mai en conseil
des ministres le président de la
république a dit le sénat s'est
déshonoré le temps est encore à l'action
ce n'est pas le moment de jouer les
procureurs je ne confirme jamais les
propos du conseil des ministres c'est
une règle de base second alors qu'avec
eux le sénat que le sénat ne doivent pas
se transformer en procureur savent où je
suis désolé de vous dire je sais pas
seulement parce que je suis ministre des
relations avec le parlement je connais
bien le sénat je pense que le scénario à
coeur je suis certain que cela aura à
coeur de faire un travail méticuleux
précis danalyse d' enquête sur non pas
seulement ce qui s'est passé dans la
crise mais qu'est-ce qui quels sont les
processus qui ont fonctionné compas
fonctionne et qui sont liés à une
politique hospitalière depuis dix quinze
ou vingt ans